التعديل وبقدر ما نحن في
أوقات محفوفة بالمخاطر ،
فقد سمح الله للمحكمة العليا
والرئيس ترامب بالتدخل ،
اسمحوا لي أن أقول ذلك مرة أخرى من
تسعة إلى صفر لحماية
الانتصارين الضخمين الثانيين للثاني
والاستماع لقد قلت هذا من قبل  ليس عنفًا بالأسلحة النارية ،
إنه السيطرة على السلاح لأن الأمر
كله يتعلق بالسيطرة ،
فهم يحاولون تلطيف الكلمات بحيث يسقط الناس على
حق ، إنها سيطرتي ، الأمر كله
يتعلق بالسيطرة على المواطنين الملتزمين بالقانون
كما
قال عضو الكونغرس بيري إن الأمر كله يتعلق
بالتحكم في الناجين الملتزمين بالقانون
وأخبرت الأمريكيين أنها
جاءت
هنا وهي تعيش هنا ، آمل أنها لا تزال
على قيد الحياة ،
فأنت تعلم حماية أوامر المخاطرة الشديدة ،
كما تعلم المتحدث
الذي يمثل سوطنا في التجمع الجمهوري لأغلبية مجلس النواب ،
لذا دونا موجودة هنا
لأنني لم أقم بإجراء واحد هذا العام
[تصفيق]
في الولايات المتحدة  من أمريكا